is like one of my favorite analogies so
in The Matrix Morpheus takes them
through a training program to teach him
one thing about agents and so they're
walking down the street and there's all
these people going going and he says
were you listening to me or are you
looking at the woman in the red dress
and he says look again looks back and
the woman in the red dress you walk by
is an agent putting a gun in his head
and I see distractions the same way
which is that the better you become the
more attractive the woman in the red
dress is and so you can say no to a six
but what about a seven what about a 12.
exactly what about hypothetical thousand
that's why having like some of the Soft
Stuff of like this is the vision this is
what we're trying to do and there's a
hundred other things I could do but each
of the cost of those things is the one
thing that matters most Warren Buffett
said that the difference between really
successful people and the most
successful people is that the most
successful people say no to almost
everything